you know as as China you know continued
to rise and perhaps India and a few
other sort of so-called
emerging markets I think with we're
seeing a redefinition of the global
geopolitical picture I think you know we
will evolve more from a single
superpower to perhaps multiple power
maybe it's not super power up it's a
multiple power picture where everybody
would will seek to work with everyone
else in a more closer manner and I
believe that now is standing a lot of
discussion about you know potassium ISM
and people trying to protect this and
that and so I I believe the world will
move to us perhaps a more globalized
environment where countries we have to
work closer together on on on a similar
agenda I think the US will continue to
play a major leadership role in many of
these major geopolitical issues I would
expect countries like China India Russia
and of course many of the Western
European powers will also play important
role I think a large you know link to
others is you know the growth of the
global multinational companies that
these companies will work across
national borders they will do businesses
you know in various countries and you
know in some cases they would have to
apply the globo's processes and systems
but in many cases they also need to be
very local you know in places like the
u.s. in China and Japan and India you
have to be very local so that ability to
combine the globalists of companies as
well as to become very local it's gonna
be a real challenge of the the leading
multinational companies but I am very
optimistic that you know we're gonna
have quite a number of these companies
who can be very successful canceller
develop the right model to take
advantage of the globalization that
we'll be seeing over time
you